Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble Buddha.
and fully self-awakened one.
So first of all, many thanks to Donatella who is translating for me.
honeying my words with her angelic voice.
Mamma mia, addolcendo le sue parole con la mia voce angelica.
Ecco.
So I'm going to give a talk on the qualities of the Buddha, the nine qualities.
So this is what we chant when we do puja.
So this evening I will talk about the nine qualities of the Buddha, which we refer to when we intone the puja.
So we chant that in the morning, eh?
So the first quality is Arahant.
And it means accomplished, somebody who is worthy of respect.
Now, what the commentators do is they begin to separate the word to give it more meaning.
Quello che fanno i commentatori è separano la parola dandogli un significato più vasto.
Ah, and the one that makes sense to me is the division between Ari and Hatta.
La separazione che per me è più valida è quella tra Ari e Hatta.
It means he destroyed his enemies.
Now the enemies, of course, are the defilements.
Now the defilements are listed as ten.
But actually in the scriptures it just means anything that is unwholesome within our personality.
And such a person has no secret evil.
Questa persona non ha alcuna male, alcuna cattiveria nascosta.
And he can say with the Buddha, with all the enlightened people, that birth is destroyed and the holy life has been lived.
che la nascita è distrutta e la vita sacra è conseguita.
What had to be done has been done.
Ciò che doveva essere compiuto è stato compiuto.
There is no more rebirth for me.
So whenever we say Arahant, that's what we mean.
Now the second one is Sama Sambuddho, which means self-enlightened.
La seconda è Sammasambuddha, che vuol dire autoilluminato.
So this is the crucial role that the first person plays for us.
E questo è il ruolo cruciale che la prima persona ha nei nostri confronti.
Somebody must have planted the first wheat.
Qualcuno deve aver piantato the first wheat.
What do you mean?
Yeah, wheat.
Yeah, grain.
Sì, qualcuno ha piantato il primo stelo di grano.
Somebody must have created the wheel.
Qualcuno deve avere creato la ruota.
And we know that Edmund Hillary and Sherpa Tenzing climbed Everest.
Sappiamo che queste due persone hanno conseguito l'Everest, hanno raggiunto l'Everest.
So once they did it, everybody else can do it, even the dogs.
Una volta che loro l'hanno fatto, vuol dire che anche tutti gli altri sono in grado di farlo, persino i cani.
Ah, so in other words, the one who initiates, who begins something, has a special place within our praise.
And so this means that the first person, the one who started all this, has a place, a special place in what we attribute to him, in the blessings we wish him.
So he is the founder of our tradition.
So without him there simply wouldn't be any Buddhism.
Now the next quality is endowed with clear vision.
quella successiva, la qualità successiva è dotato di chiara visione.
Or we can say direct understanding.
O di comprensione diretta.
And virtuous conduct.
E anche di condotta virtuosa.
So this means that he has understood the cause of our problems
Questo vuol dire che gli ha compreso la causa dei nostri problemi.
And of course of his own problems.
Naturalmente partendo da quelli che erano i suoi propri problemi.
And because of that his actions are always virtuous.
E grazie a questo le sue azioni sono sempre virtuose.
So remember that everything begins from this misunderstanding.
It's a misunderstanding as to who we are.
Presuming ourselves to be human beings, that's all, we seek happiness in the sensual world.
Ah, and this creates what we call an attachment.
Which means we are dependent on the sensual world to make us happy.
Questo vuol dire che dipendiamo dal mondo sensoriale perché noi si possa essere felici.
And this leads us to certain unfortunate qualities.
E questo ci porta ad avere delle qualità sfortunate.
Greed, aversion and fear.
Avidità, avversione, paura.
And all the rest?
All the rest of human misery.
So, in other words, he is somebody who has understood the path and understands it to be a path of purification.
Vuol dire che è stato colui che ha compreso il sentiero, il cammino da percorrere e che questo cammino è un sentiero, un cammino di purificazione.
The next quality is translated as someone who has completed a journey.
So this includes all the training that he went to with his two teachers.
And his own discovery of the path.
And don't forget that he also did some very severe mortification exercises.
So in other words, by practicing in the wrong paths, he eventually found the right path.
So this often happens to us.
First you make mistakes and then you find the right way to do something.
E questo è anche quello che accade a noi.
Prima facciamo degli errori e poi troviamo il modo giusto per fare le cose.
Now the next one is a seer of the worlds.
La qualità successiva è una persona che vede i mondi.
Now, this does not refer specifically to seeing other realms of being.
This is to do with the worlds that we create.
These are the ones that we manufacture our little universes.
Si tratta quindi di quei piccoli universi che noi stessi costruiamo, andiamo a costruire.
So sometimes we're in the hell realm, when we're depressed and upset.
A volte ci troviamo nella dimensione infernale, quando ci sentiamo molto infelici o depressi.
Sometimes we were in the animal realm, when we used to get drunk, but we don't do that anymore.
A volte ci trovavamo nel regno animale, per esempio, quando usavamo ubriacarci, ma ovviamente non lo facciamo più.
And then there's the hungry ghost realm, when we are very greedy.
Poi c'è la dimensione, il reame, diciamo, degli spiriti affamati, quando siamo pieni di avidità.
And sometimes we're in the human realm, where we have some sort of intelligence, some sort of wisdom.
Occasionally we get lost in anger and we become angry gods.
And of course occasionally we are bathing in absolute wonderful joy and pleasure.
So these are the worlds that we create within ourselves.
So somehow we have to go beyond these worlds.
In qualche modo dobbiamo riuscire ad andare oltre questi mondi.
And that's what we do whenever we practice vipassana.
Ed è quello che facciamo ogni qualvolta pratichiamo la vipassana.
Because when we practice vipassana we can see these worlds appearing in front of us.
So this is, that was the knower of the worlds.
The next is translates literally as a coachman driving an ox or a horse.
E quello successivo si traduce come un guidatore che guida il carro trainato da un bue.
It translates better as an incomparable trainer of trainees.
Ah, si traduce meglio come un addestratore incomparabile di addestrati, di persone addestrate.
And of course he has left us certain rules and regulations that we can follow.
Ovviamente ci ha lasciato delle regole, delle indicazioni che noi dobbiamo seguire.
So on the negative side there are the five precepts, the eight precepts.
And on the negative side there are the 5 and 8 precepts.
And then of course for the monastic life, all the rules of the Vinaya.
And on the positive side, he's given us the ten perfections.
And the four Brahma Viharas, the four great illimitables.
Love, compassion, joy and equanimity.
La gentilezza amorevole, la compassione, la gioia compartecipe e la equanimità.
The next one is, he is a teacher of gods and men.
Gods and human beings.
Quello successivo è un insegnante di dei e esseri umani.
Ah, esseri umani.
So this, of course, refers to the Dharma, all the teachings of the Dharma.
Questo ovviamente si riferisce a tutti gli insegnamenti del Dharma.
And, of course, the practice of Vipassana.
Of all the absorption techniques.
And, of course, how to live the spiritual life in ordinary daily life.
And number eight is buddho which is the one who knows.
L'ottavo è buddho, cioè colui che conosce.
So this is simply saying that he knows how we create the world of samsara, the world of ongoing.
Questo vuol dire semplicemente colui che conosce il modo in cui noi costruiamo il mondo del samsara.
And the escape.
So remember he said he only taught two things.
Dukkha and the end of Dukkha.
And Dukkha is all the miseries that you can think of.
And then the final quality is Bhagavā, which means exalted, sublime.
Yes, it's an honorific, like we say of the Dalai Lama, his holiness.
Yes, it's an honorific term, like when we refer to the Dalai Lama as his holiness.
So those nine qualities he has accomplished and has destroyed all his defilements.
Quindi queste nove qualità ha raggiunto e distrutto, è arrivato alla fine della strada, ha distrutto tutti gli inquinanti.
He was self-awakened.
Autoilluminato, autorisvegliato.
He has a clear understanding of our situation and because of that virtuous conduct.
He has completed the journey and he did it skillfully.
He knows all the worlds that we can create and how to get out of them.
conosce tutti i mondi che siamo in grado di creare in noi stessi e anche i modi per poterne uscire.
He's a wonderful trainer, a coach.
È un addestratore, un istruttore straordinario.
Yeah, life coach.
Un istruttore di vita.
And he's also a great teacher.
Ed è anche un grande insegnante.
He has penetrated the human condition, he is the Buddha.
And therefore we consider him to be exalted, sublime and blessed.
So I hope my words have been of some assistance.
Oh, sorry.
That's this silly Google assistant.
A very great annoyance.
So I hope my words have been of some assistance.
Quindi spero che le mie parole vi siano state di aiuto, di ispirazione.
That I have not caused confusion.
Spero di non avere contribuito a confusione invece.
And that by your devotion to the past you will be liberated.
E che grazie alla vostra devozione nei confronti del cammino voi possiate essere liberati.
Sooner rather than later.
prima piuttosto che più tardi, più in avanti nel tempo.